c'était en avril dernier une
manifestation du collectif 0 chlordécone
après plusieurs mois de travail la
vingtaine d'associations avait élaboré
une plate-forme de 50 de piste contre la
pollution au chlordécone plateforme
promise au préfet ce dernier devait leur
répondre ce matin les associations ont
fait le point pour l'instant nous
n'avons aucune réponse de monsieur
préfère donc ses 52 points sont arrivés
et nous attendons qu'il puisse nous dire
ce qu'il en fait nos enfants nous
demanderons des comptes parce que cet
empoisonnement le sait bien c'est pour
plusieurs siècles
ce taux de chlordécone dans les terres
ne va pas disparaître si elle et les
produits qui sont fabriqués qui sont
issus des sols ne sont pas contrôlés
mais un vrai contrôle les gens vont
continuer à s'empoisonner
si la population semble désormais bien
informés des risques encourus avec ce
pesticide
elle l'est beaucoup moins d'une autre
réalité il est possible de s'en protéger
filière sans chlordécone tests sanguins
informations au public
le salut n'est en tout cas pas dans
l'importation
à sortir
les vagues ali sont liés aux pesticides
parce que il y a quinze aliments fruits
et légumes qui sont extrêmement nocif
pour la santé à cause de leur tour en
fait si ce que nous consommons tous les
jours par exemple les pommes de terre
les folles les pêches les raisins un tas
de choses qu on aime beaucoup mangé ici
[Musique]
consommer local et ce en chlordécone
c'est donc la solution
le collectif a lancé notamment un
recensement des agriculteurs et éleveurs
dont les produits sont sains mais l'état
de son côté fait-il vraiment son maximum
non selon ce collectif lorsque le préfet
annonce qui a eu 2000 contrôles l'année
dernière et qu'on nous faisons un petit
calcul arithmétique
eh bien on constate que uniquement avec
le nombre de grandes surfaces de moyenne
surface quand on bat 5,24 contrôles par
an si on ajouté 34 communes de la
martinique
on descend on tombe à a3 et quelques
virgules contrôles par an et s'il faut
ajouter tous les points de vente qui
sont multiples à la martinique nous
tombons à 0,03 contrôles par an donc
c'est inadmissible alors c'est vrai qu'à
des contrôles mais c'est contre la ne
sont pas à la hauteur de du drame qui
nous arrive
en cette veille de vacances on attend
une directive du ministère de
l'agriculture pour savoir si le taux de
chlordécone admis dans les viandes et
les volailles repassera à 20
microgrammes où sera maintenue à son
maximum
comme révélé il y a quelques mois